nur für einen fototermin wird er nicht
nachgefahren sagte der kanzler jetzt war
er dort und man muss fragen was ist
dabei herausgekommen was hatten er und
seine drei kollegen im gepäck
eu-beitritt mehr waffen mehr druck auf
moskau versprochen wurde den ukrainern
schon viel sie haben nur nicht so viel
zeit wie ihre besucher aus dem westen
reise nach kiew warme worte oder echte
hilfe wir müssen reden mit diesen gästen
roderich kiesewetter cdu
verteidigungsexperte
von der spd außenpolitiker ralf stegner
katja gloger
autoren und russland expertin
zugeschaltet aus brüssel zdf
korrespondentin anne gellinek
und andré melnik der ukrainische
botschafter in deutschland
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
die begrüßt die gäste in der sendung
ausgesprochen herzlich jetzt war also
endlich da der bundeskanzler und er war
nicht alleine hier sehen wir noch mal
bilder von heute nachmittag hermetik ist
bei uns botschafter der ukraine in
deutschland zwischen beleidigter
leberwurst aus großem herzen dank
zwischen verzweiflung und echte hoffnung
was würden sie sagen wie empfinden sie
diesen tag heute politisch das war eine
wichtige besucher wie die ukraine auf
jeden fall aber hoffentlich auch für
bundeskanzler selbst weil er ja vor ort
sich ein bild machen konnte wie
verzweifelt die lage ist und welche
verwüstung diese angriffskrieg land
gebracht hat und dementsprechend hoffen
wir dass der kanzler auch
das gefühl diese dringlichkeit bekommen
hat was die hilfe betrifft und was die
ukraine am meisten dass sich wünschen
auch aus deutschland sind ihre
erwartungen erfüllt
zum tage glaube ich schon denn beim
thema eu mitgliedschaft wissen wie
schwierig das war in den letzten wochen
haben wir versucht hier dafür zu werden
und ich muss ihnen sagen dass das nicht
einfach war und jetzt die worte die in
kiew wir gehört haben geben uns auf
jeden fall ein bisschen hoffnung dass
diese beschluss des europäischen rates
nächste woche auch positiv ausfällt und
wir hoffen dass der kanzler nicht nur
diese unterstützung verkündet sondern
auch jetzt dafür sorgt dass diese
einstimmigkeit die ja benötigt wird in
brüssel auch in den nächsten tagen
erreicht wird da sind wir glaube ich
oder befürchte ich noch nicht über den
berg ok ich werde mich dafür stark
machen hat er heute gesagt herr
bundeskanzler dass eben diese
eu-kandidatur gelingen wird ralf stegner
ist bei uns von der spd als erfahrene
außenpolitiker lange haben wir darüber
gesprochen ob und wann der kanzler
hier fahren soll war das jetzt der
richtige zeitpunkt in ihren armen ich
finde ja insbesondere ist ein starkes
europäisches signal wenn man gemeinsam
mit dem französischen staatspräsidenten
mit dem italienischen präsidenten und im
rumänischen regierungschef kommt und
damit deutlich macht dass es eine
gemeinsame europäische haltung gibt und
wenn man die frage ihrer sendung
aufnimmt warme worte oder echte hilfe
beides die warmen worte die sich uns
auch gehören weil man auch freundschaft
ausdrückt und verbundenheit und ich
würde nicht gering schätzen dass es ja
was ist wenn man weiß man braucht eine
einstimmige abstimmung in europäischen
union dass sich die chefs größere länder
so eindeutig öffentlich festlegen das
ist nicht gewöhnlich das ist ja
ungewöhnlich und insofern auch von daher
genau der richtige zeitpunkt ein paar
tage vor dem gipfel 7 müssten eigentlich
enttäuscht sein weil im grunde hat olaf
scholz vladimir seelands geologie lenski
in den meisten punkten recht gegeben er
hat sich für die eu beitritts kandidatur
ausgesprochen und er hat gesagt wir
werden waffen liefern so lange nötig vom
soll ich enttäuscht sein ich tue mich in
der tat schwer mit dem thema
waffenlieferungen man es darauf verengt
wenn aber immer der meinung gewesen man
muss natürlich die ukraine unterstützen
unser politischer humanitär ökonomisch
auch militärisch in dem rahmen den wir
gemeinsam mit den alliierten vereinbart
haben ich halte nichts von der logik ist
darauf zu verhängen und immer mehr und
immer schwerer waffen zu diskutieren
aber insgesamt finde ich ist das ein
gutes zeichen wenn der präsident der
ukraine jungen chef der ukraine heute
sagt er sei vollständig zufrieden ich
habe sehr genau zugehört ist ja sehr
scharf befragt worden ob er denn noch so
ein bisschen zufrieden sein also
vollständig zufrieden mit dem hat es das
große signal gedeutet und das waren
beide seiten zufrieden sind was wir mehr
und dann sind wir bei der cdu bei uns
ist der verteidigungsexperte und
außenpolitiker roderich kiesewetter herr
käser wehrte ein bisschen mehr als ein
fototermin wasser und schon oder er hat
ja auch lange gewartet und daran
gearbeitet dass es funktioniert und es
war schon ein starkes zeichen ich sehe
dass zwei differenzierter als verstehen
aber es war ein sehr starkes zeichen
dass hier die drei zentraleuropäischen
gründungsmitglieder der europäischen
gemeinschaft dabei waren und rumänien
als ein land das eine lange grenze hat
aber ich sehe ist dahingehend
differenziert weil die nuance sehr
unterschiedlich waren marco hat sich
sehr klar dazu bekannt dass die ukraine
gewinnen muss und dass waffenlieferungen
schnell erfolgen müssen und man hat da
sicherlich akzente gesetzt und auch
gezeigt dass er europäische führerschaft
anstrebt ich muss auf der anderen seite
sagen es ist gut dass unser
bundeskanzler gereist ich war ja selbst
mit friedrich merz in europa ich kenne
den eindruck das macht was mit einem
ball her bewegen aber die frage der
waffenlieferungen deutschland ist das
land das sehr viel ankündigt sehr viel
spät macht aber das was wir direkt
liefern könnten wie marder oder leopard
die am anfang von der ukraine auch
angefragt waren und zwar sehr intensiv
liefern wir immer noch nicht aber vier
maß werfer wurden auf drei reduziert und
so was ich wünschte mir da schon noch
etwas mehr konkret ist aber unterm
strich ein positives signal das ist auch
wieder die ganze packung wir werden zu
den einzelnen waffenlieferungen
natürlich noch kommen wir merken uns
dass sie auch sagen zur hälfte
wenigstens war das ein nennenswerter
termin katja gloger ist bei uns nicht
nur moskau kennerin wenigstens oder
russland kennerin genauso gut kennen sie
washington und trotzdem die frage an sie
heute und an diesem abend was denken sie
was wird dieser besuch ausgelöst haben
in moskau
ich erinnere ganz gut mit welcher mühe
und mit welchem desinteresse die eu nun
vor gut zehn jahren ein
assoziierungsabkommen mit der ukraine
verhandelt hat wie erstaunt und
schockiert man dann gewesen ist als der
damalige ukrainische präsident
janukowitsch dieses
assoziierungsabkommen auf massiven
moskauer druck und große geld
versprechen hin und wieder nicht
unterzeichnet hat und dann eine spirale
sagen des konflikts und ja des krieges
dann in gang gesetzt worden ist die
mai-daten demonstration die annexion der
krim und ein krieg der 2014 begonnen hat
und wenn ich das vergleiche
war das heute ein guter tag weil die
ukraine jetzt so mühsam es sein wird und
so lange es dauern wird aber sie hat
eine europäische perspektive
und damit eine politische und
ökonomische
zukunftsperspektive und das kann
wladimir putin eigentlich nicht anders
interpretieren als eine große politische
niederlage
das heißt er wird es als eine niederlage
wahrnehmen wichtige frage noch mal
gleich vorneweg ohne dass wir lange
darüber diskutieren müssen wenn man
jetzt automatisch weniger gas nach
deutschland
liefert ist das nicht eine reaktion auf
diesen besuch der vier es ist also nicht
eine strafe auf diesen bezug besucht der
hier glauben sie dass auch robert habeck
hat es heute sofort dementiert man
konnte sich nicht so richtig sicher sein
ob er sorge macht oder aus echter
kenntnis werden wir gegebenenfalls
bestraft und zwar recht zügig ob es
einer der vielen tests platini putin
versucht uns an unseren schwächsten
stellen zu treffen eine dieser
schwachstellen ist energieversorgung und
schon probiert man dass anne gellinek
ist uns zugeschaltet aus brüssel zdf
korrespondentin eben aus der
europäischen hauptstadt und der großen
zentrale wir haben alle das hier schon
thematisiert erst vor das neue europa
exakt vor drei monaten machten sich
polens tschechiens und sloweniens
präsidenten auf den weg und nun fährt
also das alte europa mit klaus johannis
als feigenblatt so ist es hier in
deutschland beschrieben worden ist diese
ist dieses misstrauen abgebaut
das misstrauen
gegenüber dem alten europa gegenüber den
zögerern ja mit diesem besuch würde ich
sagen haben sie den befreiungsschlag
versucht es ist ja sind ja nicht
irgendwelche europäer sondern es sind
die drei gründungsmitglieder drei große
wichtige eu länder die da zusammen
zusammen mit dem rumänischen präsidenten
hingefahren sind und natürlich ist das
wichtig dass die drei sich heute jetzt
festgelegt haben und gesagt haben wir
wollen dass die idee dass die ukraine
den beitrittskandidaten status bekommt
allerdings würde ich natürlich
vorsichtig sein
beim satz de die ukraine hat jetzt eine
europäische perspektive bin ich noch mal
kurz zusammengezuckt denn wir wissen ja
dass die europäische union aus 27
mitgliedern besteht und dass eine
schwachstelle die auch putin sehr gut
kennt die einstimmigkeit in dieser in
diesem verein ist und man muss jetzt
sehen ob die drei es schaffen alle
anderen skeptiker zu überzeugen dass
tatsächlich die ukraine den
beitrittskandidaten status bekommt und
mit welchen auflagen sie gehen bekommt
da kommen wir sicherlich auch noch dazu
und ist das an wir reden im grunde nicht
von jahren sondern wir reden von
jahrzehnten oder einem sammler landtag
also sankt nimmerleinstag so weit würde
ich jetzt nicht jeden aber wir reden
ganz bestimmt von einem jahrzehnt das
würde ich schon sagen denn wir wissen ja
alle dass das ein mehrstufiges verfahren
ist und alle diese stufen müssen immer
wieder mit einstimmigkeit bestätigt
werden also im grunde wenn wir ehrlich
sind ist das was heute da angekündigt
wurde der beitrittskandidaten status
heißt erst mal
sachlich gar nicht sondern es ist eine
politische ankündigung zu sagen wir
wollen die ukraine in die eu aufnehmen
und der nächste schritt wäre dass alle
27 mitgliedsländer der europäischen
union sagen wir wollen
beitrittsverhandlungen mit denen
aufnehmen das ist der nächste wirkliche
schritt der dann was bedeutet und auch
da sind länder des alten europa sind
nämlich frankreich niederlande dänemark
und portugal immer noch zu überzeugen
und dagegen wir kehren noch mal zu der
frage zurück ob dieses und was dieses
treffen heute gebracht hat es gab noch
vor zwei tagen
von wollen sie denn ski heftige kritik
an bundeskanzler die dann tatsächlich
sogar von wladimir klitschko
retourniert wurde und vielleicht hören
wir uns diese kritik von selen ski noch
mal an er warf dem bundeskanzler vor
einen spagat zu machen
wir brauchen von kanzler scholz die
sicherheit dass deutschland die ukraine
unterstützt er und seine regierung
müssen sich entscheiden es darf kein
spagat versucht werden zwischen der
ukraine und den beziehungen zu russland
sondern man muss sehen wo man seine
prioritäten setzt
deutschland war ist und bleibt partner
der ukraine
darüber kann es keine zwei meinungen
geben und shows hat dazu längst ein
klares bekenntnis im bundestag gegeben
da widersprechen sich zwei interessante
und wichtige köpfe aus dem land selbst
stolz darf kein spagat versuchen sagt
volumina sie lenski zwischen russland
und der ukraine
glauben sie dass dieser heutige tag herr
melnik ein ende dieses spagats ist oder
ist es jetzt ein spagat auf einem bein
oder auf 2
man muss sehen dass russland für
deutschland
auch in der zukunft und nach diesem
krieg wahrscheinlich ein wichtiger
faktor bleibt und deswegen bin ich da
eher skeptisch dass man heute schon
sagen kann dass dieser spagat oder diese
diese
kontroverse zwischen den beiden quasi
schon gelöste aber der präsident hat
recht ich glaube dass gerade jetzt wo
wir diesen krieg haben diesen brutalen
barbarischen krieg mitten in europa dass
das die deutschen aus
ihren erfahrungen lernt quasi jetzt
vielleicht doch die ukraine mehr unter
die arme greift weil das auch im
deutschen interesse ist über gesagt das
ist kein geschenk an die ukraine das ist
etwas was aus unserer sicht auch im
ureigenen interesse der bundesrepublik
ist weil kein anderes land hat mehr
profitiert von der osterweiterung der eu
wirtschaftlich aber auch politisch und
wir glauben dass die ukraine einen
beitrag dazu leisten kann wir wollen ja
keine bittsteller die diesen prozess
sein sondern wir wollen auch etwas
leisten übrigens auch im bereich der
sicherheit wir haben gezeigt dass wir
durchaus in der lage sind nicht nur uns
zu verteidigen sondern auch andere
partner und da sage ich auch das thema
nato könnte vielleicht auch wieder
aktueller werden und deswegen es geht um
darum dass das die deutschen tatsächlich
den worten taten folgen lassen und dass
wir diese unterstützung wirtschaftlich
aber auch und darüber haben wir noch
nicht gesprochen auch militärisch dabei
verstärken können sie hat da heute wem
ins gewissen geredet bei diesem treffen
also das treffend war alleine war das
schon wichtig weil weil wie gesagt die
drei
größten nationen in der eu haben uns
diese ehre gegeben und
versucht unter einem risiko natürlich
sehr ländern haben geheult als der
kanzler angekommen ist am bahnhof in
kiew ich glaube das waren 1 1
beiderseitige prozess der präsident hat
ganz bestimmte dem kanzler die
prioritäten nochmals vorgelegt und und
gesagt was wir uns wünschen dann die
perspektive ist zwar ein sehr starkes
signal und deswegen nicht möchte dass
wiederholen weil wir wussten dass da
sehr skeptisch gesehen wurde noch bis
zuletzt das war auf jeden fall eine
starke message an die ukraine aber weil
diese zukunft wird noch lange vor uns
liegt ja gebrauchen jahre um die beiden
vertragen dann zu beginnen und jedes
kapitel abzuarbeiten
um dann kommt man wangen eine karte zu
entsprechen aber wir müssen jetzt
überleben und um das zu tun brauchen
eben schwere waffen diese zwei fragen
sind sehr eng miteinander verknüpft und
dann bleiben wir noch mal bei dieser
frage herr kiesewetter
friedrich merz sie haben es schon
erwähnt als auch sie haben nicht nur
schockiert besucht sondern sie sprachen
beide davon dass olaf scholz eine zweite
agenda habe was ist diese zweite agenda
was würden sie sagen tut er also in
jedem fall wäre es wichtig dass olaf
scholz deutlicher erklärt wie er sein
handeln macht ich will dass bei spielen
heute in der presse kommt prinz sagte er
die ukraine muss leben es geht aber im
moment ums überleben der ukraine es geht
darum die ukraine eine überhaupt
verhandlungsposition zu bringen dass sie
in der lage ist auch verhandlungen zu
führen und nicht ein diktat frieden oder
was auch immer zu akzeptieren und da
wünschte ich mir vom kanzler deutlichere
worte hinsichtlich einer breiteren
waffen unterstützung wir sind das land
in europa das tatsächlich über die
meisten vorräte an schützen und
kampfpanzern verfügt weil die anderen
das schon längst exportiert haben und
wir tatsächlich von der industrie die
möglichkeit haben 100 panzerhaubitzen
2000 zu liefern über 30 meter über 30
leoparden aber die genehmigung hat das
kanzleramt nicht erteilt gleichwohl das
außen und wirtschaftsministerium ihre
bedenken aufgehoben haben und den
genehmigungen zu bestimmt haben also da
würde ich mir eine erklärung wünschten
warum er ist nicht machen er es nicht
macht heute hat er erklärt dass er genau
diese panzer nicht liefern kann und
hörsälen ski eigentlich auch viel mehr
und er artillerie braucht als
ausgerechnet marder und leopard panzer
was auch ein wenig schon kritisiert
hatte wer twitter da sagen sie das
stimmt nicht also ich sehe das anders
weil ich es anders erlebt habe nicht nur
in der ukraine vor sechs wochen sondern
auch vor zwei wochen als der
außenminister cholera da war der sehr
deutlich gesagt hat zunächst wird jetzt
artillerie gebraucht aber wenn die
russische artillerie
eingedämmt ist dann werden die
bodentruppen die da voran gehen und
dafür braucht man kampf panzer und
schützenpanzer also hier geht es
tatsächlich auch um militärische fragen
die wir stegner sicherlich richtig sagt
auch eingebunden müssen werden müssen in
finanzhilfen das ist der andere punkt
die finanzhilfen die international
zugesagten im zweistelligen bereich sind
erst sehr wenige tröpfelt es sind als
sechs milliarden euro geflossen also
auch da sind noch erhebliche baustellen
damit die ukraine weiterhin
zahlungsfähig bleibt aber ich bleibe
dabei es wäre sehr hilfreich gewesen
wenn der bundeskanzler das sehr klar
erklärte frage an katja gloger auf der
einen seite die formulierung vom spagat
zwischen kiew und moskau auf der anderen
seite das bemerken der politischen
opposition hier im lande da gäbe es eine
zweite agenda woran kann man das fest
machen dieses gefühl an den telefonaten
die es von
makro und stolz und draghi mit putin
gibt und der vermutung dass der unter
der hand über irgendetwas geredet wird
oder auch nicht geredet wird folgt ja
das wird sich ja der eine oder andere so
interpretieren es geht ja bis dahin dass
man das staaten gibt die sich wünschen
dass man überhaupt gar nicht mehr mit
putin spricht ich empfinde es bei allen
herz leid was man haben mag wenn man
sich die ereignisse in der ukraine
anschaut jeden tag ich empfinde es
dennoch als politisch richtig dass man
diesen kommunikationskanal offen hält
und auch immer wieder deutlich macht
dass es in dieser frage eigentlich gar
keinen spagat geben kann und ich glaube
der besuch der drei heute war ein
zeichen
dafür dass es mit diesem russland mit
putins russland
keine wirkliche gemeinsame zukunft geben
wird und das ist dass der eiserne
vorhang zwischen russland und europa
gefallen ist und dann ist die nächste
frage natürlich
haben wir haben sie das gefühl dass die
interessen deutschlands herrscht eine
identisch sind mit den interessen der
ukraine
das ist eine wichtige frage weil sie
markiert und wie sehr wir uns die ziele
der ukraine zu eigen machen wir
unterstützen die ukraine wir
unterstützen sie finanziell haben sie
uns noch lange gekommen damit stärker
unterstützen wir unterstützen sie
humanitäre unterstützen sie politisch
auch militärisch im rahmen dessen was
wir für vernünftig halten wobei ich
schon sagen was dieses dieses mit der
zweiten agenda ist schon ein bisschen
unverfroren weil das ja ein fahrrad
vorwurf dahinter steckt der und
realistische betrachtung angestellt
werden wer sich wie ausdrückt was ich
erlebe ist das eine enorme
geschlossenheit gibt mit frankreich mit
england italien mit den vereinigten
staaten von amerika kommission versucht
das immer anders dazu denn das ist aber
nicht so da wurde das ganze hat sehr
eindeutig gesagt die ukraine gehört zur
europäischen familie hat sich sehr klar
festgelegt wir tun das was wir tun
können aber wir machen natürlich nicht
automatisch das was gefordert wird die
ukraine hat was ich verstehe gefordert
eine flugverbotszone einzurichten am
anfang der auseinandersetzung das haben
nicht nur deutschland abgelehnt sondern
die nato insgesamt aus guten gründen und
der bundeskanzler hat übrigens auch zu
stimmen hören das was er tut ich habe
gestern gelesen ich habe eine neue
unfall die bevölkerung wurde gefragt
teilen sie richtig dicker bundeskanzler
zauderer zwei drittel der befragen name
sagt nein er macht das genau richtig und
da gibt es überhaupt keine zweifel dass
dann nicht gezaudert wird und dass wir
nicht hin und herschwanken sonderseite
der ukraine stehen trotzdem ist klug hat
um besonnenheit notwendig und gefragt
und will die interviews geben und sagen
die russin dann aber doch noch das ist
sehr einfach aber zu sagen was jeweils
gebraucht und ich war sehr angetan von
den präsidenten zu dieser frage heute zu
hören wenn die übersetzung richtig war
ich habe nur die deutsche übersetzung
davon gehört habe ist gesagt worden dass
herr lenski die frage eindeutig bejaht
hat und eben nicht gesagt hat das sind
unsere forderungen erfüllt geblieben
oder ich traue ihm nicht
ich hätte jetzt gedacht er steht nur
dass sie doch ein bisschen was andere
sagen wir können noch mal schauen was in
den letzten wochen und nicht heute dazu
schon geliefert wo ist es so dass
deutschland einer der wichtigsten
militärischen unterstützer der ukraine
ist niemand lieferten ähnlich großem
umfang wie deutschland es tut mir
ehrlich gesagt ist deutschland etwas
später als einige unserer nachbarländer
dazu gekommen was die waffenlieferungen
angeht
was den umfang der gelieferten waffen
angeht ich bin nicht bereit diese
aussagen zu bestätigen die sie eben
gemacht haben ehrlich gesagt ich bin mir
nicht sicher was die zahlen angeht
also da ist ein kanzler mit einer
auskunft zitiert es ist der präsident
der ukraine zitiert wir könnten jetzt
natürlich aufzählen was deutschland
alles geliefert hat wie sehr sich die
ukraine und andere länder wünschten vor
allem das baltikum die polen die briten
dass wir uns doch ein bisschen sputen
mögen das sind dinge die werden an ihnen
nicht vorbeigegangen darf ich ihnen auch
sagen da wird darüber diskutiert dass
eine staatssekretären sich ihre
ausgedrückte es gebe eine nadel
vereinbarung oder so was fakt ist dass
die amerikaner die briten die italiener
die franzosen die deutschen in der sache
exakt das gleiche tun auch vereinbart
haben welche waffen jetzt geliefert
werden aber eben keine kampfpanzer
liefern keine kampfflugzeuge liefern das
machen sie gemeinsam alle nicht das tun
die nicht ohne miteinander zu reden
dafür gibt es offenbar ja gute gründe
das nicht zu tun dass es den ringtausch
gibt auch das ist vereinbarte politik
das kann man alles kritisieren das
findet aber statt und wenn jetzt
mehrfach raketenwerfer
deutschland großbritannien usa das
miteinander vereinbaren ist es auch ein
teil von gemeinsamkeit ich muss das
nicht in jedem einzelnen punkt richtig
finden aber die behauptung deutschland
stehe auf der bremse die anderen wollen
eigentlich was ganz anders ist falsch
und ich weiß ja als jemanden der
kiesewetter weiß dass auch wenn man
gelegentlich in die vertraulichen listen
hineinschaut was ich regelmäßig tue dann
stellt man auch fest dass in der
öffentlichkeit behauptet wird stimmt
dann meistens auch gar nicht davon
zwischen präsident äußert sich fast nie
öffentlich zu dem was er tut und hat
sich sehr viel klarer über in einem
interview geäußert dass der kampf als
abfall schwelle die zu liefern also also
ich länger zeigen gemeinsam vielleicht
setzen wir uns alle noch mal in den
umstand kurz zusammenzufassen was andere
länder schon geliefert haben dass er mal
auch vorbereitet viele nato partner
halten der ukraine schnell und umfassend
polen schickte 230 t 72 panzer
tschechien 61 schützenpanzer und
frankreich lieferte ein dutzend cesar
haubitzen allein das kleine estland
leistet militärhilfe für 220 millionen
euro und lettland für 200 millionen
allen voran schickten die usa waffen für
4,4 milliarden euro unter anderem
helikopter haubitzen abwehrraketen und
drohnen
also nochmal die frage die ukraine
brauchen waffen und sie wünschten sich
diese waffen auch von deutschland die
lieferungen der anderen länder waren
gemessen an ihrem bip größer und sie
waren nennenswerte finden sie immer noch
dass wir alles getan haben ich finde
dass wir wenn man dieses gesamte
spektrum sie ankommen ist nicht verengt
auf die militärische frage dass wir sehr
wohl die ukraine nach kräften
unterstützen und die verengung auf die
militärische halt ich persönlich auch
für falsch ich glaube und das ist heute
auch angeklungen dass wenn man
miteinander spricht auch über die frage
gesprochen wird dass der krieg
irgendwann ein ende finden muss eine
politische lösung finden was die
übrigens nicht das füge ich gleich hinzu
über den kopf der ukraine hinweg gehen
darf am ende entscheide die ukraine als
selbständiger staat was sie macht oder
was sie nicht macht aber kriege ein
militärisch und das tut dieser auch
nicht an sie werden am ende politisch
enden und deswegen können wir nicht nur
über waffenlieferungen reden manche
reden ausschließlich über
waffenlieferungen und ich sag mal ich
stelle nur in der sache fest und den
haben sie auch nicht widersprochen mit
ihren beispielen ringtausch ist das eine
aber wenn sie die faktor anschauen
welche art von waffen geliefert werden
dann unterscheidet sich das was die usa
frankreich großbritannien und in
deutschland tut nicht voneinander und
das ist der punkt um den es geht der
bundeskanzler hat immer gesagt es gibt
keine alleingänge wir handeln gemeinsam
mit den anderen die bevölkerung finden
das gut der deutsche bundestag hat sich
übrigens in seiner entschließung da
kamen fünf von ihnen noch dazu ansonsten
war das unsere entschließung unsere
fraktion hat einstimmig zugestimmt dazu
bekannt dass sie umfangreich helfen dass
das im übrigen tausch machen also die
vorwürfe sind meiner meinung nach falsch
und man kann darüber streiten manche
wünschen sich mehr und immer schwerer
waffen darüber kann man reden ich glaube
nicht dass das die richtige debatte ist
wie wenn neue waffen reden weil darum
geht es glaube ich in der zukunft
ohnehin herr kiesewetter sie sind
opposition in diesem land und können und
vielleicht trotzdem bei der beantwortung
der frage helfen wir haben auch nicht
zum ersten mal hier darüber diskutiert
haben die usa denn ihre abrahams und
ihre bradley schon in die ukraine
geliefert oder haben das sind panzer
oder haben sie das aus gutem grund nicht
getan sondern es ist eben erst mal der t
72 in die ukraine gegangen die usa
bereiten die lieferung von abrams vor
aber viel entscheidender ist deutschland
hat im wert von etwa 300 mio euro
geliefert die amerikaner mehr als das
zehnfache wir haben etwa in der gleichen
größenordnung geliefert die erst land
und litauen zusammen ein bisschen
weniger aber das wesentliche aus meiner
sicht ist dass wir was die
waffenlieferungen angeht
hinter den fragen zurück bleiben wir
haben im bundestag ersticken gesprochen
wir haben im bundestag kein wirklich
beeindruckenden entschluss gemacht wir
haben die initiative ergriffen dann hat
die opposition artig regierung eine sehr
klare nein sehr weitreichenden antrag
gefasst hat dankenswerter weise unsere
punkte aufgegriffen aber passiert ist
nichts und wenn er steht noch von den
listen spricht die er der kanzler
vorgetragen hat im bundestag so ist
deutlich geworden dass seit ende april
nichts wesentliches mehr geliefert wurde
und was geliefert wurde waren
panzerfäuste flugabwehrwaffen das war am
anfang auch benötigt aber in der
zwischenzeit wurden schwere waffen
benötigt und die ring täusche sind nicht
funktioniert weil polen wollte 400 bis
600 t 72 liefern und ab deutschland um
leoparden nachgefragt was blieb erstmal
relativ lange liegen dann hat polen aus
eigener kraft wie sie richtig berichtet
haben über 200 t-72 geliefert und hat
nicht akzeptiert dass wir ihnen
kampfpanzer anbieten die weit hinter dem
zurück geblieben was sie aufgerüstet
haben die t2 und sehen sich sind besser
ausgestattet als die relativ alten
leopard wir hätten das erklären müssen
der öffentlichkeit aber wir sind weit
hinter unseren möglichkeiten
zurückgeblieben die industrie hat die
bereitschaft erklärt zu liefern und die
bundeswehr hat ja bestände aber die
industrie wäre bereit gewesen über 50
leopard und mara bereits im april zu
liefern weitere später und die industrie
wäre auch bereit rund 100
panzerhaubitzen
panzerhaubitzen 2000 zu liefern das
wurde nicht gemacht
nein natürlich nicht und weil die
regierung nicht entschieden hat das ist
ja der knackpunkt und deswegen werden
wir auch das kann ich ja auch ankündigen
dass nächste woche thematisieren und
werden versuchen das in einer ratte und
mit einem antrag noch einmal deutlich
herauszuarbeiten dass deutschland mehr
kann und wir stehen ja hinter der
regierung weil wir über diesen antrag
den über 500 leute zugestimmt haben
diesen antrag mehr machen könnten wir
tun es nicht und das ist bedauerlich
weil die ukraine den gedanken möchte ich
noch einfügen natürlich in die lage
versetzt werden muss zu verhandeln muss
erst mal überleben und in der lage sein
dann diese verhandlungen zu führen und
wenn es in freier selbstbestimmung ist
dann bitte mit der möglichkeit ist auch
freier selbstbestimmung zu tun nämlich
gestört katja gloger würden bei der
argumentation der deutschen tatsächlich
helfen wenn es nennenswert haubitzen
eben vielleicht auch panzer in welcher
größenordnung immer von deutscher seite
schon gegeben hätte um uns aus dieser
situation heraus zu bringen dass man uns
immer unterstellt mit einem halben fuß
findet ihr diese alte beziehung zu
russland eigentlich viel wichtiger und
wir interessieren euch nicht und ihr
seid dabei und
ich glaube wir sind uns eigentlich dass
die wirtschaftliche großmacht
deutschland zu einem früheren zeitpunkt
schon hätte mehr an waffen liefern
können und auch sollen
ich empfinde es als
wichtig das sagen diese lieferung jetzt
fortgesetzt werden und zwar für einen
möglicherweise
unübersehbaren zeitraum denn ich denke
dass auch das dazugehört sich auch in
diesem wichtigen punkt ehrlich zu machen
wenn wir sagen die ukraine hat auf lange
sicht eine beitrittsperspektive zur eu
wenn wir sagen wir müssen die ukraine
wir wollen die ukraine
unterstützen in ihrem abwehrkampf gegen
den russischen aggressor wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass bleibt die mir putin einen
krieg gegen die ukraine führt aber
gleichzeitig einen krieg gegen den
westen auf ukrainischem territorium
führt müssen wir bereit sein auf lange
sicht diese unterstützung durch zu
halten sowohl ökonomisch als auch
militärisch als auch politisch mit all
den schwierigkeiten auf die man dann
auch in der europäischen union treffen
wird und das glaube ich ist eine ganz
ganz gewaltige aufgabe und sie ist
glaube ich ebenso wichtig wie die
lieferung von panzern und
dass wir auch über die nachhaltigkeit
reden wir können anne gellinek nochmal
danach fragen auch das war ein ergebnis
des gestrigen tages erst zehn prozent
der zugesagten waffen seien in der
ukraine angekommen so war aus kiew zu
hören das ist aber zusammengefasst
wurden für alle geberländer also auch
nach brüssel noch mal die frage gibt man
uns berechtigterweise die schuld da
hinten dran zu sein oder gibt man uns
einfach die schuld weil man uns die
schuld geben möchte und sich hinter uns
verstecken kann also
vielleicht eine kleine einsicht aus dem
europäischen maschinenraum also herr
stegner natürlich wird das auf der
europäischen ebene schon so wahrgenommen
dass die deutsche regierung zur
ankündigung macht aber dann doch fast
immer hinter diesen ankündigung erstmal
wieder zurück bleibt und dass sie nicht
vorne dran also als antreiber weder bei
den sanktionen noch bei den
waffenlieferungen
wahrgenommen das ist einfach so das sage
ich nicht weil ich deutscher bin sondern
weil das auf europäischer ebene so
ankommt und die frage war die zehn
prozent also ich glaube wir haben das
gestern beim nato-treffen auch
verschiedene
alliierte politiker gefragt amerikaner
waren sehr freundlich und haben gesagt
sie
könnten eigentlich mich feststellen dass
die einzelnen nato alliierten die nato
selber liefert ja nicht nur die
einzelnen nato-partner die liefern dass
die schon täten was sie könnten und dass
es im moment wohl eher das problem ist
dass eben auch nicht mehr so viel da ist
also christine lambrecht hat ja heute
gesagt wir die von drei von diesen
mehrfach
raketensystem eigentlich waren
angekündigt vier aber wir können nur
drei weil dann irgendwann steht unsere
eigene verteidigungsfähigkeit in frage
und das scheint vielen nato partnern so
zu gehen weshalb man ja jetzt auch
überlegt ob man die unausgesprochene
vereinbarung dass man eigentlich keine
ganz modernen nato waffen in die ukraine
liefert weil man fürchtet dass die
russen sie arbeiten könnten und
rückschlüsse ziehen können auch für
diese systeme dass man hier jetzt auch
ein umdenken bei der nato sieht dass sie
sagen die sowjetischen
waffen reichen auch gar nicht mehr aus
wir haben gar nicht mehr genug munition
für die wir können die auf die lange
strecke gar nicht der ukraine liefern
und deshalb denken sie jetzt darüber
nach die nato-partner eben auch moderne
nato standard waffen zu liefern
dazu werden wir noch kommen weil das
bedeutet natürlich auch ein neues
zusätzliches problem herr männicke sie
sind in dieser debatte natürlich nicht
außenstehender sondern ihr präsident
niemals außenstehender gewesen sondern
ihr präsident und sie dazu reklamieren
ja häufig genug dass von den deutschen
dazu wenig kommt werden sie auch am ende
wenn die ukraine feld sagen die
deutschen sind daran schuld oder geben
sie uns einfach die schuld wenn hier
viele so wir geben sind deutschen diese
chance und das sei eine historische
chance
spätestens heute zu beginnen viel mehr
zu tun und ich kann alles oder italien
was er stecken er sagt aber fakt ist bis
zu diesem tage gibt es in der ukraine
kein einziges schwere waffe aus
deutschland im einsatz obwohl die
franzosen die die briten sogar die
norwegen die polen ich meine anstrengend
franzose werden ja eigentlich auch
kritisiert
diese haubitzen sind schon längst im
einsatz und habe sich bewährt diese und
viele andere aus polen norwegen sogar
kleineren ländern und deswegen es geht
jetzt nicht um schuldzuweisungen sondern
es geht darum dass mindestens oder nach
diesem besuch und er war wichtig von
herrn scholz in kiel dass diese
erkenntnis da ist dass man doch viel
mehr tun könnte und sollte und
deutschland kann das tun es ist nicht so
dass wir etwas verlangen von ihnen und
sie jetzt bloß stellen möchten oder die
verteidigung schwächen hier in
deutschland wir wissen dass deutschland
über 800 fuchs transportpanzern
verfolgte oder oder 300 leopard 2 und 3
100 made dh aus den beständen könnte man
eventuell nach unserem wissensstand
aufgestellt
via twitter schon richtig gestellt was
die deutschen da jetzt rüber reichen
sollten aber auch die industrie und da
muss ich jetzt auch ein kiesewetter
recht geben es geht ja um schnelligkeit
es geht um schnelligkeit weil jeder ein
tag kostet so viele menschenleben und
deswegen wir haben wir haben keine zeit
wir können es sich leisten jetzt zu
warten bis dann irgendwie die
entscheidung hier kommen sondern das was
hier verfügbar ist und das kann eben die
industrie liefern hätte schon seit
monaten liefern können aber es ist nicht
zu spät diese entscheidung zu
unterstützen
und deswegen möchte ich nur an den
kanzler heute auch nochmals appellieren
zu überprüfen zu hinterfragen diese
zurückhaltung in bezug auf die waffen
die schon sofort lieferbar wären und wir
brauchen wir brauchen auch diese älteren
systemen mader und leopard 1 panzer die
sind über 40 jahre alt aber wir wissen
dass die uns zugute kommen dass sie
menschenleben retten können und dass sie
uns auch erlauben können über die frage
zu reden dass wir die gewitter die schon
seit über 100 tagen besetzt sind im
nordosten jetzt wo tausende dörfer und
städte unter kooperation stehen sie auch
zu befreien dann mit anti panzer
systemen können wir das nicht tun das
heißt nur mit schweren waffen und
deutschland ist in der lage das zu tun
darum geht es jetzt haben wir verstehen
denn darüber schon natürlich gesprochen
und die zeit drängt tatsächlich sehr
weil zu einem anderen punkt der wahrheit
gehört dass die gelände gibt wenig oder
die gebietsgewinne der russen ja
nennenswert sind 20 prozent der ukraine
sind mittlerweile von russen okkupiert
und es gibt von sam passte mir aus 2015
diesen guten satz mit der yogamatte in
der hand stoppt man keinen völkermord
das war damals seine begründung für die
militärische unterstützung des fanden
sie das damals richtig bekämpfung des
iris entschuldigung fanden sie das
damals so richtig und was wäre heute
falsch daran dass man diesem land helfen
wir reden nicht darüber dass jemand
nicht halten will und wir geben noch
nicht über pazifismus bin überhaupt kein
pazifist und ich weiß sie haben in
deutschland die demokratie nur weil die
alliierten kriegs tun hat sie deutscher
militärisch besiegt haben und darüber
spricht niemand wo wir aber nicht
reden sonst ich lerne jetzt ganz viele
neue militärexperten kennen die also
überall möglich waffensysteme reden
können genau wissen dass militärische
und das mache ich mir nicht so eigen das
kann ich nicht ich kann nur sagen wir
reden auch über menschenleben deswegen
ist es völlig richtig wenn es telefonate
gibt auch mit putin dass wir zum
beispiel verhindern dass es eine
hungerkatastrophe gibt in denen wir das
daran ist putin schuld aber das muss
hergestellt werden wie das getreide ist
vor ort stattfinden können dass darauf
hin dass wir auch einen punkt über die
heutige rede worden ist die enorme
bedeutung haben und manche dieser punkt
haben auch eine größere bedeutung als
einzelne meinung zu einzelnen
waffengattungen und ich würde immer
wieder behauptet wenn damals und heute
zusammen auftreten tun nur so als seien
sie eigentlich in welcher ziehen sie
jetzt das ist doch quatsch die sind
heute zusammen aufgetreten wie das alles
genau wird man darf auch mal das was
gesagt wird auch ernst nehmen und nicht
immer dahinter eine andere agenda suchen
und ich sehe eine große einigkeit ich
finde das richtig über uns auch nicht
nur dass du die ukraine unterstützen
sondern es sind natürlich auch dafür
sorgen dass ist ja krieg sich nicht
ausweitet auch das ist ein punkt der zur
verantwortung gehört doch nur wenn man
den russen einhalt gebietet also wenn
wladimir putin sagt er ist eigentlich
peter der große dann machte er deutlich
dass er an der ukraine nicht haltmachen
wird dann möchte er offensichtlich nicht
nur die ukraine immer alles richtig und
im übrigen gehört ja eigentlich nach den
haag vor das kriegsverbrechertribunal
das ist nicht der punkt auf der anderen
seite die sanktionen sind ja auch nicht
nichts warum machen wir das eigentlich
weil wir die russen dazu zwingen wollen
den kurs zu überdenken und dazu gibt es
um uns auch diese kommunikation ich bin
froh dass die drei präsidenten mit dem
telefonieren ich wollte nicht in dem
land sein wo wir nur noch darüber reden
dass wir nur noch schießen und dass er
überhaupt keine diplomatischen kanäle
immer wo soll das enden und dann machen
sie uns eine menge menschen die ihre
sendung gucken sorgen darüber in
deutschland auch die wollen das video
kann und es gibt große unterstützung für
die flüchtlinge die hier sind aber sie
wollen auch dass das mit besonnenheit
passiert dass man hat übrigens heute
muss ich einsehen zugleich fragen accor
hat heute gesagt quatsch hermeling
gleich fragen dass er 2009 10 von
monotonie lenski darum gebeten wurde mit
putin zu telefonieren und das ist sogar
eine explizite bitte der ukraine damals
war diesen kontakt nach moskau zu halten
über den französischen präsidenten also
da beklagt man sich offensichtlich auch
über umstände die sogar die ukrainische
seite sich mal gewünscht hat es geht
darum dass seit jahren seit ende
1990 wurde muß es geht nicht mehr
sprechen wollte und um diese
sprachlosigkeit zu überwinden
noch vor dem krieg war das notwendig
dass wir vermittler warten und das waren
und sind hoffentlich immer noch die
deutschen und die franzosen
und das war ja naheliegend dass das eben
damals nur die kanzlerin dann der neue
bundeskanzler olaf scholz und makro
diese rolle übernehmen übernommen haben
das war richtig dann natürlich brauchen
wir eine diplomatische lösung aber sie
haben recht wenn sie sagen wenn putin
nicht erkennt dass er militärisch keine
weitere lang gewinne macht dass er nicht
mehr so brutal vorrücken kann und
betreibt übrigens auch eine
psychologische kriegsführung jetzt im
don masse hat einen zipfel internets
ausgewählt die gesamte bucht die gesamte
kraft seine truppen konzentriert und
natürlich macht er da gewinnen mit ihrer
der zweitgrößten armee der welt jeden
tag bei dörfer und das erzeugte auch
hier in deutschland so ein gefühl der
unbesiegbarkeit von russland und
deswegen auch dann diese resignation
sollen wir denen helfen doch darauf
drängen dass der frieden wird schnell
wie möglich jetzt erreicht werden kann
und das ist falsch wir müssen uns nicht
einschüchtern lassen werde von den
atomwaffen noch von von diesem versuch
psychologisch uns alle zu beeinflussen
und warum machen sie dann auch die
flüchtlingshilfe hier in deutschland
schlechter wenig warum sagen sie dass
sie glauben dass sich ukraine hier in
deutschland nicht mehr wohlfühlen nein
das habe ich nicht gesagt und das möchte
ich auch heute auch bei ihnen widerlegen
das wurde aus dem zusammenhang gerissen
was ich gesagt habe war das weil die
menschen ohne sind viele menschen die
gekommen sind nach deutschland diese
diskussionen hören in deutschland dass
ihnen ein und hat geholfen wird und das
schätzen wir und dafür sind wir dankbar
und zwar sowohl der bundesregierung hat
den deutschen diese aufgenommen haben
und auf der anderen seite
hören sie diese diskussionen ja
waffenlieferungen wissen wir nicht ob es
sich lohnt das hier das gefühl haben
oder nicht alle aber manche von ihnen
dass das land das sie verlassen mussten
wegen des krieges wie möglich in stich
gelassen wird das heißt es gibt schon
viele kritikpunkte die man auch offen
glaube ich ansprechen aber auch bewusst
für den kopf dass es ihnen bewusst ich
möchte noch mal sagen dass wir auch ich
persönlich weil ich jeden tag auch mit
diesen menschen reden also es ist nicht
so dass ich irgendwie aus der luft was
ging die aufgegriffen habe wir schätzen
dass die regierungschefs das hat der
präsident gesagt auch heute nochmals
diese hilfe die von der bundesregierung
kommt von den kommunen von den menschen
von vielen tausenden ehrenamtlichen und
das möchte ich heute nochmals
bekräftigen dass wir schätzen wir wissen
das zu schätzen und wir hoffen dass das
diese hilfsbereitschaft oder deutsch ein
vielleicht sollte man sich nicht
beleidigen wir gehen zurück zu dem thema
was wir eigentlich besprechen wollten
katja gloger der blick nach vorn es wird
ein langer krieg werden es ist
mittlerweile ein
wirkungskreis es ist ein krieg der über
eine ganz ganz lange grenze hinweg geht
und der dem ukrainischen volk der
ukrainischen armee nun natürlich auch
ein zusätzliches problem auf lädt
nämlich dass sich über eine ganz lange
grenzen verteidigen zu müssen was umwelt
schwieriger ist als eine stadt zu
verteidigen so die frage an die nicht
militärexperten wie lange wird das
ukrainische militär wie lange wird die
ukraine wird das ukrainische volk dieses
durchhalten und auch warten darauf dass
lieferungen endlich kommen mein größter
respekt gilt den widerstandswillen und
dem verteidigungs willen der
ukrainischen menschen
andererseits scheint es zumindest im
moment so zu sein dass sich sagen die
militärische lage zugunsten russlands
entwickelt in dornbach
aber eben auch in dem jahr großen teil
sahen des des südens die von russland
kopiert worden ist und dass wir die mir
putin im moment alles daran setzt diese
geländegewinne nicht nur militärisch
sondern zu konsolidieren sondern eben
auch politisch zu konsolidieren im
rahmen dieser sogenannten russi fi
zierung seit dem 24 februar bekommt
jedes kind jedes kind das seit dem 24
februar zum beispiel in der stadt
saison-ende geboren worden ist bekommt
mittlerweile automatisch all die
russische staatsbürgerschaft sie wenn
sie telefonieren die telefonieren nur
noch mit russischen
mobilfunk betreibern und so weiter und
so weiter also erschafft alle
voraussetzungen
diese
okkupierten gebiete irgendwann russland
anschließen zu können
das ist ein sehr sehr sehr großes
problem
weil es die politischen spielräume
natürlich ziemlich eng macht und
deswegen die große sorge ja auch sagen
im westen dass dieser krieg
einem langen langen langen
zermürbungskrieg
bedeutet am ende wählen auch wir auch
wir im westen durchhalten müssen um der
ukraine
beiseite zu stehen denn hat die ukraine
verteidigt ja auch uns in gewisser weise
eine artillerie duell sagt man sei das
nun geworden die ukrainische armee für
die ukrainische armee zählt im grunde
genommen alles was große reichweite hat
viel davon und offensichtlich auch
neueren datums sein muss
1100 kilometer ist die umkämpfte front
inzwischen lang zu lang für die panzer
und kanonen der ukraine viele alte
waffen aus sowjetzeiten sind inzwischen
zerstört auf twitter forderte selensky
berater projekt jetzt mehr und vor allem
moderne waffen
1000 haubitzen
300 mehrfach raketenwerfer 500 panzer
2000 gepanzerte fahrzeuge und 1000
drohnen
wir machen unsere partner täglich darauf
aufmerksam dass nur eine ausreichende
anzahl moderne artillerie der ukraine
einen vorteil und schließlich das ende
der russischen tyrannei im don was
sichern könnte
gestern kündigte nato-generalsekretär
jens stoltenberg an
ich erwarte dass die nato versammlung
einem umfassenden hilfspaket für die
ukraine zustimmen wird um der ukraine
langfristig beim übergang der ausrüstung
aus sowjet zeit hin zu einer modernen
nato ausrüstung zu helfen
hin zu einer modernen nato ausrüstung
von der ausrüstung aus sowjet zeit zu
einer modernen nato ausrüstung herr
kiesewetter sie haben es vorhin schon
angedeutet 1000 und nicht nur sieben
oder acht 500 und nicht nur zehn werden
da sogar die amerikaner überfordert mit
dem was die ukraine eigentlich brauche
ich glaube wir müssen hier uns mal in
die lage der ukraine versetzen es drohen
hungersnöte kultur wird vernichtet
familien sind auseinander gerissen
zehntausende tote im zivilen bereich und
auch in den streitkräften
das macht was mit einem land das land
ist in der gefahr zu zerfallen und putin
hat der ukraine das existenzrecht
abgesprochen
und wenn es was vorhin richtig gesagt
hat darum geht dass die ukraine ja auch
unsere freiheit verteidigt spricht die
ukraine teil der regelbasierten ordnung
im rahmen der europäischen union werden
möchte dann schauen viele augen auf die
art und weise wie europäische union und
nato dieses land unterstützen oder eben
auch nicht und wir wollen wir künftig
gegenüber partnern in nordafrika
beispielsweise oder im nahen und
mittleren osten regeln durchsetzen wenn
sie erleben dass wir den
überlebenswillen der ukraine
tröpfchenweise versuchen aufrecht zu
erhalten also ich glaube dass
stoltenberg sehr klar erkannt hat dass
es jetzt mit einem schwung voran gehen
muss im moment sind leider waren gefragt
es ist auch wiederaufbau gefragt ist
alles richtig aber wir können nur etwas
wieder aufbauen das auch wiederaufbau
fähig ist und ich glaube dass
wesentliche jetzt hier das ist auch der
punkt der für unsere bevölkerung so
wichtig ist dass es ein langer
abnutzungskrieg werden kann und wenn wir
massiv helfen vielleicht der krieg
schneller beendet ist weil russland
durch die sanktionen aber eben auch
durch den massiven militärischen
widerstand dann einlenkt das muss ja das
ziel sein und ich hoffe dass diese
einsicht bald wächst und da sind länder
wie deutschland frankreich und italien
natürlich ganz besonders gefragt weil
sie sehr wirtschaft stark sind wir aber
trotzdem noch mal bei dieser neuen
qualität von waffen denn es sind ja auch
neue waffensysteme die im grunde aus der
nato kommen das wäre jetzt eine frage
noch mal zur anne gellinek unbedingt
nach brüssel wie groß ist denn die sorge
unter den europäern und auch unter den
nato mitgliedern dass der nato know how
und das nato material in die ukraine
geht das ist ja wirklich etwas
substanziell anderes als aus den alten
sowjet beständen die ukraine zugeliefert
ja wieso sorge gibt es die es bisher nur
hinter den kulissen
geäußert worden ich laut ausgesprochen
worden aber natürlich ist das auch ein
grund warum bisher keine ganz top
modernen waffen in die ukraine gegangen
sind man hat immer gesagt die
sowjetischen die die waffen sowjetischer
bauart können die ukrainischen soldaten
besser bedienen das ist sicher richtig
aber jetzt kommt man eben an einen
wendepunkt an dem offenbar eben diese
sowjetischen waffen nicht mehr
ausreichend man hat auch nicht mehr
genug nachschub für diese waffen nicht
genug munition und deshalb setzt jetzt
ein umdenken eine ganze gerade bei
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
gehört er hat gesagt wir müssen
verdienten bürgern phase die ukraine mit
modernen nato waffen ausrüsten also
diese zurückhaltung scheint jetzt zu
schwinden da gibt es ein umdenken geben
weil die situation sich verändert hat
und weil dieser krieg offenbar jetzt in
eine entscheidende phase andrej melik
das sind raketensysteme
raketenabwehrsysteme raketenwerfer an
denen ihre soldaten die ukrainischen
soldaten ausgebildet werden müssen das
geschieht jetzt unter anderem eben auch
in idar oberstein es geschieht
hoffentlich an anderen der welt auch
noch können ihre soldaten die nicht
bedienen oder haben sie diese sorge
nicht
also wir lernen schnell auch bei youtube
videos auf solche erfahrungen hatten wir
am anfang des krieges und mussten wir
tun
das läuft sehr schnell und wir haben
panzerhaubitzen 2000 diese sieben stück
wir sollten hoffentlich nächste woche
schon ankommen
die ausbildung ist abgeschlossen sehr
erfolgreich beide baden beginnt das
gerade dieser prozess und das heißt bei
anderen systemen könnte das auch genauso
schnell gehen und ich möchte auch hier
ganz kurze
begrüßen und auch danke sage nochmals
dem kanzler auch persönlich für die
entscheidung das system est und zu
liefern also die erste jedes tier aber
vor allem ist das ist ein
luftabwehrsystem
also das modernste system dass
deutschland produziert wirklich state of
the art und wir hoffen dass nach dieser
entscheidung auch weitere kommen dann
diese eine einheit könnte eine großtat
wikis oder und tester oder ratgeber in
schutz nehmen und mit menschen legen und
deswegen deutschland hat hier das eis
gebrochen und das heißt man könnte auch
weiterhin gehen dass das problem ist
lieferzeiten weil das das sei schon ein
halbes jahr so was zu produzieren aber
wir müssen leider davon ausgehen dass
dieser krieg noch wahrscheinlich lange
dauern wird und deswegen wir müssen
schon heute dafür sorgen dass die
ukraine und die systeme bekommt dass wir
auch die munition dafür haben und im
westen kann man das bestellen ist auch
der westen zögerlich und nicht nur
deutschland katja gloger